pay attention just before the amazing to
read out the emergency evacuation
announcements Jujubee require a bit
right and ability would you please leave
early for the nearest available exit to
the change very simply point will be the
public car park at side of the Civic
sweet please do not deny p light of your
health evacuation to create any
belongings please do not belong return
to the building until given permission
to do so by the grounds that the cancer
song you can place that this Mason will
be audio recording can I show that
police arrive so welcome chairman caps
ahead of it a cheap detective and monday
and the chat be four MK
argh leaving everybody and welcome to
our first meeting of the new here I hope
everybody else are the same there and I
would like to wish everybody are they
happy new year and hope we have a very
enjoyable meetings while I'm still
tremor I'd like to introduce the
Reverend Kim here she's associate
priests for white cream and that area
and she has come to now instead of our
own homes on holiday and more things
else you've apparently very much I like
to echo best wishes for 2016 having the
year to to you all so let us pray
Almighty God we bring me for you the
agenda to tonight's meeting maybe we
even have been entrusted responsibility
to govern and to make decisions for
those who have elected us / the best of
motives and really interests of all for
the benefit of all in prayer minds and
the desire to hear all points of view
including those who may diametrically
opposed the opposed to our own from
openness and debate our debate make us
gracious and courteous to friend and
opponent alike with a real sense of
working together for this district in
the areas that are represented by each
of our district councillors at the same
time we can enter your blessing the work
of all the employees watch for District
Council you maintain implement and they
possible the works and words that are
denoted discussed and formed into policy
and decisions finally let us pause for a
moment to remember in silence our own
nation and other parts of the world in
conflict and suffering natural disaster
if you know words and would like to i
might be join me now in the words the
prayer that Jesus taught us the words of
the family prayer the Lord's Prayer our
Father which art in heaven hallowed be
thy name thy kingdom come Thy will be
done on earth as it is in him give us
this day our daily bread and forgive us
our chances as we believe them that
trespass against us and lead us not into
temptation but deliver us from evil for
thine is the kingdom the power and the
glory forever and ever and may you know
his sights and the coming days and weeks
the blessing of God the Father Son and
Holy Spirit amen thank you very much oh
I wish you were ignored again in this
which
nice kid or watching high-poverty think
I please be seated
the first item is apologies my handsome
and we have this page on really like
really it's Joanne we have apologies in
the apt in your face from counselors and
this is lonely customary cousins of the
council where houses and okay I
understand nice them oh hey German
castle is the basis of Canada we should
well that's all we care services were
through here any other colleges council
is a counselor this is high or she's not
very good and that's where each other
any other projects no well thank you
very much flat oh how dressy
declarations of interest if anybody got
any Oh somebody else can't you like on
my cell on tinder stanyan st beso I
don't know but the fact each other's
interests
I'm talking system now you don't this
one the other people might do but I
contended that the waiter will see thank
you very much crystal made here but then
if you draw board the first bit so
that's number two and now we have now
going two thousand three it's a preview
of impelling districts antinodes what
mr. ah stop it even like same people
this before we go any further thank you
Thank You chairman with the electoral
review of the district included bimini
through you hugging districts and
polling places across the district so
the allowing of the new wards the
council has always had a policy whereby
were impossible each polling district
serves as a polling place for that
particular area in terms of maximizing
flexibility it would be practicable to
retain that policy with an extension
where I could include polling districts
ordering the area in question such an
arrangement we mean as long term could
be identified should the situation arise
where a polling place is unavailable
within a particular poem district
details of the proposed poem districts
of ended to report and have been
published and consulted upon in
accordance with the regulations full
councils being asked to firstly
designated hugging district and the
polling district bordering it is the
polling place for that poem district and
since techniques endorse the final
arrangements for poking districts so
carefully
appendix Thank You chairman how about
any person are you all happy with what's
been said I can flip this is a powerful
force to the safe amounts of visitors
you saying that we have a policy that
shows that any sense like it any
district probably fit can have a polling
station in and return suppose over
applied to having flute before that boat
except for of a traditional Bulls now
but so you can listen a [ __ ] that any
politician I'm having that brick
fireplace German previously if there
wasn't a polling station identified in
upholding district there were three
occasions when an adjoining war would be
utilized the suggestion here is to if
the authorities in the situation where
that isn't a polling station within a
poem district and that isn't the
situation at the moment what if it d by
this stuff in estrogen
barely can look into the adjoining
polling district which is actually a
lesser area than the previous whole
water agent who would allow conversation
to be identified if that seems a lot
and lastly as an example of that in
hopeful north and lashing down they've
always shared at the hook with an ass
again they've already remove my name to
one side of the road and the other side
of the other end the other one so i
could see that's a simple thing that's
likely to happen with the same pinky
take anybody else on to ask any question
yes council okay well it doesn't matter
how they don't take about the China
Sturgis a question related to along this
sort of line and see some other
authorities have used the temporary
buildings to make sure that there was a
polling station within a particular bull
pen settings the taxis that would be a
possibility
German at is included in consideration
these covering polling stations are
looked at and it has been in place
previously anybody else counts mom now
you go Russian John a lot what's been
put into this and I think that the
opposite hook I know that he's put into
this as well at his team but just to say
I think the point that was made of our
temporary accommodation is that I think
many of these places are going to be
deviating client now services making
sure that they composited disabled
Discrimination Act so I think there are
considerations there and I think in each
case I know that helps with a lot of
work need to try to find out where the
best place for that is so I've if you
notice it's working w the parts if you
like it obviously be the new areas for
some of those will change accordingly of
course there will be consideration
relating to both perish elections town
council elections as well as other
elections that will come forward and
there are a few this year as you as you
may know you might even get a referendum
one doesn't know but I've got back to my
first point so thanks very much your
schoolwork done explained as anybody
else on well then I put to you the
recommendation of the Hannibal this is
on page three point two and it's
mendations old but it's a demica
desperately horny district and probably
districts ordering it adds a polling
place for that holding district my
grandfather's icicle one in it came up
with i happen to endorse our final
arrangements of crony districts and set
out in the appendix on your happy with
that group to the other of Shub
hands-free another gifs thank you very
much you need to pick it up and Witter I
have closed a meeting but please before
you go any further I have now finished
with the lead entity center I'm now
going to sign up and I what I want to
come down Bob fit